is that strategic like when you go when
you go and finally address Katt Williams
seen it on The Breakfast Club like at
the beginning of this sort of New York
wing of the press to him do you go like
yeah this is how I'm gonna get this out
of the way at the beginning of the press
tour it's done or did it just come up
with those guys no that was about that
wasn't even about me that was about
Tiffany right it's not a you know it's
not a Katt Williams came hard thing you
know people want to make it that it's
not I could care less I don't have any
desire to have a feeling or emotion
towards him if we record him a cold
we're not we're not that's fine this was
about simply supporting people of color
when they're in a position of success
like there's a huge argument of the lack
of opportunities that people of color
gets so when we do get them I want to
make sure that was standing proud behind
those that are getting because they're
opening up the doors for other people of
color to come through you don't want to
see guys just attacking for no reason no
no not now not now now with the now by
the way the times are now when we're
actually making steps in the good in a
better direction you know I mean when
I'm what I'm seeing progress when I'm
seeing multiple movies with diverse cast
and you know you're looking at a
different lens than what we've seen in
the past because of the level of
attention that we've drawn to certain
diversity issues then it's like yo this
is dope so I don't want to see I don't
want to see our own attacking our own
that's the part that frustrates me one
more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM f
[Music]